hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the clutch chess
international tournament that started
today so many of you have already
requested it and for very good reasons
it's it's really awesome
as the title suggests its is just a wild
game but as the online chess scene
progresses with time now we're kind of
having this huge chess boom there are so
many tournaments online everyone is
having invitationals everyone is having
huge money prizes
the format's in which the tournaments
are played are getting weirder and
weirder and this tournament is no
different
we've seen well a lot of games are being
played a lot of matches are being played
we've seen it in the Magnus Invitational
in Doris ABI rapid challenge so here I'm
just gonna read it out it's from the
chess 24 website so this is the format
of the game the two the two two hundred
and sixty five thousand dollars clutch
chess International is an eighth player
knockout taking place from 6 to 14 to
June 2020 with world champion Magnus
Carlsen the top seed each match consists
of 12 games so every match will be
played in over the course of 12 games
but with the twist that games 5 & 6 are
worth double points and games 11 and 12
are worth triple points so even if from
the first 10 games you are behind games
11 and 12 are worth triple points so
it's pretty pretty crazy the clutch
games have an extra $10,000 at stake in
each match which prices rolled over if
the games end in draws so the time
control is 10 minutes per player for all
moves with a 5 second per move increment
from move one no draw offers are allowed
before move 16 the event is organized by
the st. Louis chess club with the games
played on leeches and the official
website of the tournament is us chess
chance comm so there we have it
I'm not gonna read out the read this out
before every game this is the first one
we're showing in the event so that's why
I'm reading it so here Magnus faces a
Jeffrey Sheung for the first round this
is Game one of their match and it's like
I said pretty crazy so sorry but a
longer intro but I want you to notice so
without further ado let's check it out
Magnus with the white
Isis opens with c4 he goes for the
English opening and we have c5 hyung who
goes for the symmetrical English we have
Knight to c3 sorry about that
and we have g6 preparing to finca to the
dark square Bishop with III preparing d4
and the bishop to well before Bishop to
g7 Knight to f6 we have d4 captures
captures and now comes d5 and we've
transposed into the plan of attack of
the caro-kann defense so Queen to b3
Magnus adds a third attacker to the d5
pawn and young just gives it up it's the
way this line is played we have C
captures on d5 and now she um just
castles so Magnus wanna pawn but it's a
double D pawn and his king is still in
the center of the board so he has to be
very careful there should be doom is of
course preparing to develop the knight
Castle kingside and so on and now Knight
to a6 the knight can come to c7 from
where you will go after the d5 pawn
bishop to f3 Magnus now also adds
another defender to the d5 pawn and now
the most common move here is Queen to b6
where you just offer a queen trade
remove one of the defenders and then go
Knight c7 route d8 and well pick up your
your gambit pawn
however Jeffery goes for b5 and it's not
a new move but it's a very very tricky
idea point is that if the point is
captured then it's very hard for for
whites to keep any sort of an initiative
for example Ruby 8 you put pressure on
the night and after a for defending
Knight c7 is very strong a6 is coming
and it's just an ugly position for white
to play and your King Gaston in the
center of the board it's not much
different if you go go for it with the
Queen if Queen captures again rugby 8
and after the Queen moves you can go
Knight the c5 Knight night not night to
c5 Knight before and you can go to d3
and well with the white king still being
in the center of the board it's not
something you want to do so Magnus goes
Knight the GTE - he prepares the castle
and now there is one there are two games
in fact the word b4 was played but here
we have worked the BA advise young and
it is a new move so already as a move 10
we have a completely new game and here
magnus goes bishop therefore he
challenges the rook
and also he takes away the c7 square
from the night which is very important
if you are planning to grab this pawn on
d5 so Rugby six by young now and now
Magnus decides whether to castle or
whether to go for this point if b4 comes
then you can no longer capture it
Magnus decides to go for it and he falls
right into Geoffrey's trap Geoffrey here
plays g5 and this is a super super
tricky idea point is you wanna now get
the bishop away from the defense of the
c7 of the c7 square and it doesn't
really help you if you go back up to g3
if you go bash up the g3 then g4 comes
and your bishop is trapped it's just
terrible
so after this g5 move Magnus has to
capture the bishop the pawn so black's
pawn structure in front of the king is a
little bit messed up however now nice
the c7 with a double attack on the
knight and Magnus is losing the piece
here so Magnus defends it with a four
but now of course a sex you attack the
paint piece and the night is is doomed
Magnus says okay we have d6 and now of
course if you capture Magnus we'll just
cat tree or night so you kind of have to
capture here on d6 with each character
son d6 and now Magnus just captures
castles and she um grabs the knife so
Magnus is down a piece however he pushes
a five and for the price of this night
he creates a past eight point which is
not ready to be pushed forward and she
has to decide whether he wants to block
with rook t6 or go rook to b8 he decides
for rook to b8 rook t6 could be a bit
more precise as it doesn't allow the
pawn to advance but he decides for rook
to b8 as it's not all that easy for the
pawn to advance the bishop and Knight
are covering a six for the moment so
night
the g3 by Magnus and now well you don't
want a long night Stewie for to put a
lot of pressure on this night here so
night the e6 attacking the bishop here
and Bishop back to e3 is there also is a
double attack you're under bishop and on
the pawn you of course don't want to
trade so Bishop back to e3 and now
Knight back to c7 and here we have a
very interesting moment in the game
Magnus goes back Bishop g5 we have night
the e6 again and Magnus retreats Bishop
III and night the c7 and it was in this
position that the players agreed to a
draw that of course is a joke here
Magnus declines the threefold repetition
with Bishop to g5 instead goes rook F
the c1 so Magnus doesn't mind being down
a piece he now once the once the play he
does have a past a pawn and he likes his
position so Bishop to e6 Sheung is of
course also now wants to play that
Magnus declined at the repetition the
Queen is under attack and Magnus puts
the Queen back all the way Queen to d1
and now Knight F to d5 and I just
putting more pressure on the bishop here
we have a six now that the bishop moved
from c8 Magnus can start pushing the
past bond we've looked a 8 and now pawn
all the way to a7 and now if this pawn
can be captured then the extra piece
will be indeed valuable however if the
pawn can remain on a 7 it will it will
be very hard for black to to do
something about it
so Queen to e7 maybe if you move the
knight maybe you can just play rook
captures an 87 however Knight the h5 now
and now the bishop here is a very strong
defender of blacks cam so now you kind
of wanna you kind of don't want to give
it up however she um finds a very
interesting idea Knight captures on e3
now okay you open up this attack on the
rook however White's queen is also under
attack so Magnus first needs to react to
this F captures on e3 and now not moving
the rook but rather Bishop h6 saying
okay you capture my rook I'm just gonna
capture on e3 and Deliver check and pick
up your rook as well
Magnus goes for this bush of character
Sunday 8 and now Bishop captures and III
with check King to h1 and now Bishop
captures in c1 so Queen captures on c1
and only now rook character Sunday 8 so
she own still up a piece but Carlsen
still with his past a pond and here
Queen to c3 Queen to c3 from here you
control a lot of very important squares
you're putting pressure on the night
you're gonna play Queen f3 if you want
to put 4
the rookie can go Queen to g3 check if
needed fall by Queen g7 so very active
square for the Queen but she hung
calculates precisely he goes Knight to
d5 he offers calls in this idea of Queen
here to here and indeed if you go for
this check like the King f8 check you go
back Queen here check black would block
with the Queen and now after let's say
97 check King has to move you will now
capture on h7 and this is the position
ashion had in mind well he still remains
upper piece and he still has to figure
out how to do something about this maybe
some like Knight to c7 fall by b4 maybe
Knight can come over here and then you
can pick up the pawn if you can get rid
of this pawn then black will do well
however Magnus doesn't go for Queen to
g3 check instead of Queen to c6 is on
the board attacking the rook here so
Shion goes back Knight to c7 defends the
rook and now Queen to b7 and here it's a
it's a very dangerous position a queen
to b8 checked could be a problem in a
lot of lines however it's not a problem
at the moment for and here ashen should
play Bishop to d5 just challenge the
Queen force this Queen to b8 check move
and after the knight blocks black will
just be better here because white
doesn't really have a move you cannot
move the rook because of just capture
Sunday 7 the Queen doesn't really have
all that many squares and whatever you
play with the night let's an idea for
them Queen b7 forces a Queen trade and
then black is just better I mean your
your upper piece there's nothing to do
about it
so after Queen - b7 Bishop to d5 is the
way to go however a shilling plays the
one move that he shouldn't he plays
Bishop to g4 and now okay the knight is
under attack and there isn't really much
you can do about it however there is one
move you can play but feel free to pause
the video and try to find this idea
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on playing the move that
we've just shown and for those of you
that just want to enjoy the show its
Queen to b8 check now now it works
because there is no Bishop on d5
guarding the rook so you don't have this
nice - eh retreat you would just
the rookin a a so instead queen tf8 was
played now okay if you captured the
night it's not a problem that's why she
played this Bishop to g4 me we were
gonna capture the night however he
missed this Knight f6 check and it
nicely connected with the bishop it's a
it's a fork
after King g7 now you deliver check
captures the Queen of course has to be
captured with the king and now just
Knight captures on g4 Magnus wins back
the piece and now it's actually Magnus
who's up upon so really it really
incredible stuff so King to e7 and now
usually when you have like an endgame
you want to start bringing your King
into the game with King g1 let's say
that sound like this but Magnus goes for
a completely different idea he plays
Knight to e3 and it's very interesting
because for example if black goes for
something like b4 with the idea of night
sorry of Knight b5 fall by real captures
an a7 is you really want to get rid of
that pawn then Magnus had in my Knights
to c4 and after night here you're just
gonna play Knight to b6 and yes black
can capture the pawn however Knight to
c8 Czech wins the rook so that was that
was the idea
and without this b4 night here black
doesn't really have a good way of
getting rid of the pawn so she only
started to bring in the King into the
game he wants to shave the King over
here and win the pawn that way
d5 not allowing any squares here and the
point is nicely protected so King goes
to c8 but now that the d6 pawn is no
longer defended Knight to f5 now with
the idea that if Knight captures you can
just capture with Czech gobble up this
pawn goblet this pawn and the white will
be better of course so came back to d7
not allowing this and now h4 by Magnus
again not even touching the King so this
is one very rare endgame where the King
remains on h1 and you are not improving
the position of your king this is a
crazy stuff so here in nice characters
on d5 but now rook to a6 and now you
cannot defend the d6 pawn so Knight back
to c7 attacking the rook and rook
captures and D sets with check King to
e8 and now rook to h6 finally Magnus
abandons the defense of the a7 pawn
but now he wants the gobble at this
point as he already has a CH 4 plate and
this is not this will not be a very
strong again an outside passport so
route captures an a7 rook captures on h7
and now tonight's the e6 so we have h
five magnets continues pushing the past
bond and she young does the same it's
not yet a passed pawn but you will
eliminate the b2 pawn and you want your
phone to be as close as possible Magnus
goes h6 and now Rock a5 going after the
night here
but now g4 defending that night so rook
the a1 check we have King 2 h2 and now
rook to a - it was a it's much better to
play rook t1 check rook to a 2 then just
rotate - because now you're threatening
this capture with check and white will
have to waste a move so look the h8
check we have King to d7 and now King to
g3 at the pond will fall you will have
to move your king either way so Magnus
does it preemptively so rook captures
and beat young also creates a passed
pawn but now h7 and here rook the b3
check we have king to h4 by Magnus and
now rook the b1 and here we reach an
amazing position because Knight G 3 here
takes away the h1 square and the white
can just win the game let's say this
check fall by bringing the Queen to the
game is enough to to be victorious with
white however after this rook to be 1
move Magnus played the g5 the point is
that if rook to h1 check then you can
move the King play Knight to h6 block
the rook and then do the same idea let's
say block this point and then promote
your own point however it's such a
disgusting engine line that I'm just
gonna show it because she um had a
chance here to to do something great
rook the h1 check is in fact the best
idea because after King g4 and b3 he
starts pushing his passport Magnus was
planning on playing Knight to h6 to
block the rooks defense of the pawn and
now rook the g1 check King to f3 and now
b2 so black also wants to get the Queen
in terror game rook to b8
preventing this but town tonight
captures and g5 which
and now king of - it seems like white is
winning because the rook is under attack
and you also get a passed pawn the Queen
however Knight the h3 check check is the
King defends the rook and you know the
game goes on
so if King e2 Knight f4 check keeps
black into the game in the game and if
King III then rook to e1 check keeps
black in the game King D - and now rook
to e8 now you defend the queening square
and also just challenge White's rook and
the point is after this captures you
first bring your queen into the game
white also must bring a queen into the
game and now Queen to b4 check and black
black remains alive because if Queen c3
check you just trade and then pick up
the rook and black will be okay here so
Magnus allowed this rook to h1 check he
didn't want to block it block it with
Knight to the g3 however it's such a
disgusting engine line for a rapid game
you simply do not calculate this so
Shion first started pushing his pawn but
now Magnus play Knight to g3 he now
prevented rook to h1 and now Knight to
f4 we have King to g4 by Magnus getting
the rock out of any out of any tricks
and now Knight to g6 going after the
rook but rook the g8 now and now cross
and threat is a simple rock characters
here followed by the promotion so B 2
and now Magnus goes for it rook captures
on g6 of course if you capture them the
Queen goes into the game so we have
worked the h1 instead and now the point
is if you capture the if you capture the
rook then you get B 1 Queen and as White
will also Queen and then black will have
all sorts of checks so what you would
have to do here is go Knight the g3
instead and then the knight will be very
helpful in defending all the checks and
the next move you will be able to Queen
black has to grab some material then you
bring a queen and eventually you will
win this
however Magnus decides and not to give
Geoffrey any chances so after look the
h1 Magnus just played the rook the b6
and it was in this position that jefra
she resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here point is
that if you go for rook captures on h7
then
fruit character son b2 and now you have
this endian where Magnus is just up a
full piece which is of course completely
winning and if you decide to queen
instead instead of capturing on h7 just
be one queen then just recapture son b1
and if it doesn't matter if you capture
the rook white Queens and if you capture
on each seven then again you're playing
an in game where you are down down a
full piece so really really incredible
game thank you all for suggesting it so
so rapidly as I wasn't really planning
and doing any covers of this tournament
today I would probably cover it tomorrow
but since you guys already suggested I
decided to do it today so that's the
game a game won a game one of 12 they
will play 11 more games I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Adam
grape oh you're a suit Ron and Mishelle
dellamonte Alexandra McNabb and Roger
Omar moves for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the clutch
just international checking up on the
for Chess Championship and your
wonderful suggestions the morphe saga
and whatever else is happening in the
chess world as there's like everything
is happening so now I think I will see
soon and have an excellent rest of your
weekend